anyone could sound like Beethoven
your music when you do oh you can do
that
[Music]
the physicality that you both got into
for the role I'm going to start with you
Vigo and first of all mastering that New
York accent cuz if I do a New York
accent it's terrible
mastering the accent first of all and
the wait game so I know you've lost
weight for roles before is this more fun
or is it just probably is I mean it's
actually well it's certainly a lot
easier and more fun to gain the weight
than to have to lose it yeah afterwards
that was just one yes true to the
character no Jam a little and all that
stuff it I had to look a certain way as
much as I could I don't look exactly
like him
did you ever the mean looks exactly like
that surely yeah did you just eat
Italian food with it were you in
character when you were at first I ate
just that I don't under Allah and a few
times would the bell on the family they
introduced me to what about coming to
the reading with the table reads me your
Pete and I don't know Vigo yet this is
like my second time you walked in you
had like three or four pizzas and that's
just nothing repeat I'm trying to lose
weight from my part he walks in with
like four pizzas he's like yeah just got
a couple of pizzas you know and it's me
him and Pete sitting around and there's
yeah yeah I think I might have a bite
out of slice Peter Peter was talking me
about that like any good any good yeah
no good okay
good does it state no I enjoyed it and I
was to be honest with you I was I was
like you're always nervous about some
ass happen in this case I didn't want to
do a caricature yeah of New York yeah of
italian-americans of the veil and the
family I wanted to be respectful and get
it as right as I could within my
physical and mental capabilities and and
it was Nick Vallelunga really helped me
start to feel comfortable by introducing
me to his family to the food
and in just their way of being yeah and
he was generous very generous with his
father's things also you know I mean
that that necklace I wear yeah with the
mother Mary medal on it that was his
that was Tony's and photographs
fortunately audio recordings were were
Tony Live was talking about the real dr.
Lee and you know all of that stuff
you've talked about your dad and how he
was a traveling performer yeah and how
he really taught a sense in you of
quality versus quantity hmm and I was
wondering because I feel like that was a
lot of Don Shurley
nose warning if you use that it along
the rule I'm always very aware of my
dad's presence in my life quality over
quantity I think that that's something
that I hold dear to me yeah most
certainly this gentleman says that I'm
not permitted to dine here I'm afraid
not
how does he smile and shake their hands
like that because it takes courage to
change people's hearts first of all you
have a theme of road trips in several of
your phone yeah talk to me about that
how it influenced the film and why you
know it's it's funny like I never
consciously go think oh I gotta make a
road trip movie but I realized now
having made a bunch that like I make a
lot of road trip yeah and yeah I love
being on the road I've driven
cross-country twenty-two times sixteen
alone and I do my best thinking on in a
car for some reason and driving and you
know there's something like if you're in
a car you you're you can't be you know
you have to drive you have to look at
the thing and yet you can't you couldn't
be if I'm at home I can't sit on the
couch and do what I do in a car because
I could be thinking well I should be
doing the dishes or I could be doing
those emails or doing this but when
you're driving you could only drive and
so you're my brain just clears up and
all the little garbagey things in it
that go away and I have clarity so yes
when I get in any kind of situation
where I'm a little confused what to do
next my wife will say take a drive so
I'll go get a roundel car and like I
live you know outside LA and we'll just
I'll just jump in a car and I'll Drive
to you know Vancouver and then fly back
you know just to get some time you know
in my head and I mean I highly recommend
it for anybody it's a great gift to be
able to be alone in your head and just
thinking for several days what do we do
about the bones we do this
pick it up Tony's boys would eat it
anyway pick it up speaking of gifts
I think Vigo said one of your gifts as a
director is that he can say a line and
there's such a great balance between the
drama and the humor in this film he can
say a line and you can say one little
thing like take a pause before you say
this word or enunciate this word more
how do you and it makes it funnier how
do you know this aside from your
incredible track record as a comedic
director but how do you know this and
can you give me an example of how that
works well I mean it's just like a gut
feeling that I'm feeling but what I love
about about working with Viggo and not
all actors have this most though but he
he'll take a line reading you know he's
as good as it gets yet he'll get the
line reading some actors they don't want
a line reading because they feel like
you're stealing from them that well you
didn't let me do it like I'm not a robot
you know but occasionally and I don't do
a lot of line readings but if it's a
like he's just missing it I will do it
and one example is just you know when
dr. Shirley is eating the chicken for
the first time favorite scene he looks
very good what no good and that's just a
Rhode Island thing that guys say Italian
guys like if you're enjoying something
don't always what no good like you have
a good meal you're eating it's like it
means that what no good it's just this
bizarre little thing but he kept saying
you know what no good and I said no no
what no good you know and I over and
over you but it's it's a minor thing it
doesn't get a laugh but it gets a laugh
- me and my Rhode Island friends who
know that expression uh favorite scene
thank you for that scene it was
incredible
real scene by the way like much of the
movie you know that we got to saw it
actually happened exactly that way we
had all these audio tapes from Doctor
from Tony lip telling you yeah I
wouldn't eat chicken and you know funny
I brought a bucket I didn't have a
chicken and he tells the whole story it
was amazing we were giggling listening
to it